é galera beleza
a desculpa decepcionar vocês mas vou
falar de um assunto sério falar de humor
mas o amor levado a sério
eu costumo dizer que o que o leva humor
a sério leve tão a sério que eu resolvi
ganhar a vida fazendo um morto mas nem
sempre foi assim nem sempre vivi de
humor aliás nunca cogitei viver o
momento passou pela minha cabeça que
isso seria uma profissão num dia é a
nossa geração a geração chamada geração
y é uma geração um dieta é uma geração
que não quer mais é os antigos padrões
que somente no trabalho é uma geração
que quer se comunicar que ia falar com o
mundo que quer passar alguma mensagem é
então eu passo para essa geração e nunca
né
não queria trabalhar no escritório com a
camisa social branca calça cinto sapato
passar oito horas no escritório é mas
então mesmo que novembro uma família de
advogados nos faz advogados nos seus
advogados é ser um caminho natural
seguir essa profissão é né pelo menos
alguma coisa nesse sentido mas aquilo me
inquietava eu não queria
é porque eu achava que podia fazer
alguma coisa eu passar uma mensagem
então eu a gente na cidade na
adolescência foi procurando que forma
vou passar essa mensagem
aí a gente vai faz aula de música faz
aula de desenho é recheado tenta fazer
um esporte uma coisa e vai só que muitas
vezes não vai dando certo no mesmo que a
gente vê que não sabe o que é verdade é
essa
é é só que aí a gente vai crescendo eu
cresci casa ensino teve uma filha e
quando vi estava dentro do escritório 8
horas com a camisa social dentro da casa
o cinto sapato e mais ainda inquieto é
não era o que eu queria para a minha
vida
muita gente deve passar por isso e passa
ainda hoje
a gente fica incomodado detalhe trancado
daquele escritório é fazendo planilha
excel reunião com o chefe
toda a gente fica ali preso né
mas se dentro a gente fica ainda aquela
vontade de se comunicar de falar para o
mundo a gente não sabe como e ali
trabalhando
é um belo dia um amigo com o mesmo
problema que eu da mesma geração que eu
venha falar comigo sobre isso a gente
nesse dia vamos fazer uma coisa pra
gente estava a sair assim essa veia
comunicativa e tudo vamos fazer um blog
blog era grande ferramenta na época
tornou-se um blog blog é legal carro
vamos fazer um blog é fizemos um blog só
que o blog demanda é você
é tempo de você e escrevendo você
fazendo postagem você fazendo a montagem
de photoshop quer dizer acaba virando um
trabalho também que que você não tem
tempo pra fazer portar é tentando ganhar
vida tentando levar pra casa e aí no
nessa coisa surgiu o microblog seria a
evolução do blog que nada mais é que
você fazer uma uma postagem em 140
caracteres é o famoso twitter é que os
caminhoneiros já fazia muito tempo né
no para-choque deles né a internet se
apropriou isso ea gente eu comecei a
fazer legal entre uma reunião e outra
por de uma coisa engraçada eu escrevo
uma notícia necessário faça uma pedra em
cima e aquilo começou a funcionar você
consegue gostar só você está passando na
rua assim uma frase sob um banco começa
a falar sozinho e as pessoas começam a
juntar ninguém fez isso mas o twitter e
meio isso você tá falando sozinho ele de
repente começa a juntar gente começa a
juntar gente muita gente
tenho mil 10 mil 100 mil pessoas lembra
que está escrevendo e aí você começa a
ficar encorajavam tá aí acho que aí que
eu vou passar uma mensagem por aqui que
eu vou me comunicar com as pessoas e aí
é mais uma vez caminhos convergentes né
'nesse nesse ambiente de twitter e de
fazer piada e eu conheci mais três
pessoas que estavam criando um site para
fazer um golo em cima de notícias
sensacionalistas é então sensacionalista
que surgiu ali em 2009 também pessoas
que não estavam muito satisfeitos com o
que estão fazendo com ele um de uma
forma de trabalhar e fazer o gol ea
gente começou a fazer aquilo ali meio de
brincadeira o negócio acabou tomando uma
proporção maior
é um outro outra coisa aconteceu nesse
período também foi que eu fui descoberto
ele por 11 o motorista da rede globo que
me convidou para trabalhar no projeto
dele uma série e então quando eu vi
estava fazendo boa profissionalmente eu
fazia de graça antes estava fazendo
então vamos pagando agora pra fazer e aí
a coisa muda de figura
primeiro é porque primeiramente fazer
humor profissionalmente é bem diferente
você fazer humor quando os seus amigos
um churrasco no barco ou até mesmo na
internet de bombeiros 1º que uma
profissão você nunca está sozinho
dificilmente você está sozinho também
uma redação com cincos dez pessoas é
porque cada pessoa vai trazer uma uma
vivência uma experiência que vai agregar
a piada piada passa a ser um produto né
a piada fazer 11 entrega você tem que
planejar o alcance daquela piada com as
pessoas vão entender que ela é porque o
amor é a identificação das pessoas no
rio que elas não conhecem então você é
procura falar de coisas que as pessoas
não vão entender vão rir porque quando a
gente a gente acha que tá rindo do outro
ela está aqui muita gente mesmo também
muita gente tem curiosidade é como é que
funciona a redação do sensacionalista
hoje você pode tornar-se um volume
grande de postagens ele é que vocês
fases se reúnem então é assim que
funciona
a gente se reúne em nossa sala
nossa relação com os colaboradores na
brincadeira é assim que funciona a
redação do sensacionalista
aqui a relação do sensacionalismo a
gente é todo dia que korda e começa a
aperceber é notar o que está sendo
falado que as pessoas estão falando o
que está acontecendo no mundo da
política
as notícias das celebridades então a
nossa redação geralmente acontece cada
uma sua casa
provavelmente eu tô de cueca na cama
desculpas a essa imagem pra vocês não
têm idéia de escolher é mas é isso
acontece a gente a gente trabalha
principalmente e assim se entende é e um
outro fator de fazer um bom profissional
que hoje em dia principalmente é vocês
uma preocupação muito grande com um com
que é apropriado fazer humor hoje em dia
há uma preocupação em mudar é romper com
velhos estereótipos de humor
geralmente preconceituosos então a gente
hoje é optar por fazer o morro é em
relação ao que a pessoa não tem pessoa é
mas o que ela faz é com essa atitude
dela não com que ela não escolheu ser
vamos escolher também mais um porque ela
é é por exemplo a gente questiona hoje
engraçados e ninguém é engraçado seguro
duas semanas e loura e português
engraçados e papagaio papagaio engraçado
é então a gente procura ter essa
preocupação cada vez mais o que é ter
uma palavra uma uma expressão que vocês
devem ter ouvido muitos toda vez que se
fala de um mundo fala se fala dessa
expressão politicamente correta
né hoje existe essa preocupação
politicamente correto e muita gente é
entretanto essa palavra se falar de essa
expressão se falar repetido a gente
costuma ter até 1 em freio com essa
expressão e porque ela parece negativa
parece que é realmente a sociedade está
muito careta a sociedade é muito chato
mas não é a sociedade mudou
a gente é convive com muitas diferenças
e acho que o humor faz parte desse
processo também de você é não mais ficar
fazendo a a graça fácil né de mas sim é
tentar uma uma crítica uma coisa mais
inteligente é e aí eu entro nessa parte
que fala da função crítica no morro
a gente acredita a gente quando faz uma
profissional hoje acredita que tem uma
uma função além de apontar um ridículo
da sociedade a gente rir do que é
ridículo ea humor joga-se facho de luz e
se digo pra trazer isso à tona e ser
discutido então eu perguntei que é
ridículo seguir o senhor fóbicos em
negras e racista
se a mulher o episódio é obviamente a
gente se a gente está tentando construir
uma sociedade mais justa e melhor a
gente vai querer apontar esses erros a
gente acha que todos os defeitos da
sociedade e assim que a gente tenta
fazer humor hoje em dia só que claro a
função primeira do humor sempre vai ser
fazer rir e fazer riehn até uma função
social também a gente vive num mundo né
louco uma rotina é aquecida e muita
coisa ruim acontece muita pressão então
vez em quando dá uma risada né pra
relaxar bom mas a gente acredita também
que o espaço que a gente vem kula o
humor é um espaço de reflexão né o
espaço para se pensar a sociedade para
se tentar construir uma sociedade mais
justa é a maneira que todo mundo né
seja contemplado é e aí também tem um
problema é quando os elevadores exagero
quando você para de falar de certos
assuntos
é quando esse politicamente correto ele
vira uma redoma que protegem determinado
nicho e isso também é um preconceito
eu não vou deixar de fazer piada com um
homossexual mas não mais por que ele é
homossexual mas com uma coisa engraçada
que ele fez como uma coisa engraçada
desse universo que em graça disso eles
rio demais deles mesmo então é tomar
cuidado para não levar para os guetos e
aí você acaba fazendo um treino
coitadismo você não pode falar com
aquele assunto ele assunto é sagrado e e
e quando se fala de sagrado no humor
também é você pensou em religião naquele
que é um dos assuntos mais tabus hoje em
dia para fazer humor
recentemente 11 um deputado no rio de
janeiro tentou propor uma lei que
proibisse fazer qualquer tipo de humor
site a charge com religião é e ainda bem
que foi arquivado se é mas essa questão
de humor e religião então daria uma
outra uma outra palestra
mas a gente é é uma luta diária é você
fazer humor para tanta gente
hoje a gente tá falando ali com milhão e
meio de pessoas em sua lista é a última
impactar 56 milhões de pessoas
então você tem que ter muito cuidado
quando fazemos a gente erra muito
mas com certeza a gente tenta não errar
porque o agente acredita no humor como
uma maneira de mudar o mundo também e eu
achei né e se essa inquietação que eu
tinha de querendo comunicade querer
falar com o mundo de querer passar uma
mensagem eu acho que encontrei no humor
né qual é a qual é a sua maneira com que
a gente quer falar com o mundo é e para
terminar
eu queria deixar aqui uma citação e do
mármore se que esse país já teve e chico
anysio
sendo do gênio mas de todos que ele
dizia assim o humor é irmão da poesia
humor é que em torno de anuncia eu como
humorista
eu não posso consertar nada mas eu tenho
obrigação de denunciar tudo porque o
amor é tudo até engraçado
muito obrigado